[Music]
so a thief
you guys know that like car break-ins
are pretty big right now right
huge big time right crime is on the rise
guys
so what um why do you think what do you
think is causing that and i'm kidding
that's not what this is about this is
about
no i'm just kidding
a uh a thief
breaks a window from a car in poland
what does he take out of the car
holy sausage
how did you but in poland is it just
sausage
yeah this is just regular
sausage
what is a beanie baby
a kid no no a dog mm-hmm
is it
please don't bust my polish joke
no it's not a polish joke
like
what like a box of sauerkraut is that is
that where it's supposed to go polish
man comes and breaks into a polish car
finds out it's his yeah
that sounds like a [ __ ]
that's good that's good no dude he's
still there he steals a unicorn a
unicycle
what that is a polish joke
how's that car he steals a different
vehicle isn't that interesting so yeah
he's so there's a guy those faceless
jokes i didn't know a unicycle would fit
uh yeah there's a um a street performer
in in uh oh oh my god this is in
portland i'm not pulling
that changes it doesn't
that certainly changes things
your unicycle yeah a unicycle in
portland you're like oh yeah i could see
that way more than poland all those
pollock jokes that we wanted to do
all gone my whole freaking 10 minute set
down the drain
oh sorry portland knuckles i was gonna
say all these all these people have a
lot of moles i bet
so yeah why does a unicycle make more
sense in portland it does doesn't it
right yeah it's weird yeah it's the
brand it's on brand yeah so there's
there's a well-known uh street performer
and he has a unicycle
and he had it
he had he it even says on his license
plate it says yoona ppr which is like
they call he comes with the unipiper
yeah that is a really interesting almost
something that you would have thought of
right now that's great it's pretty
interesting right so he's the unit piper
he has that on his license plate they
steal his unicycle and now the guy his
name is brian kidd
he says that he followed the police
report the police obviously don't think
he's going to get his legendary unicycle
back
i wonder if they actually knew how to
ride it away
i think they wrote it away that shit's
hard you kept falling you know they're
like boom i always needed this [ __ ]
right i didn't they're like
like falling and [ __ ] or did he walk
away with the unicycle or do you think
somebody had a vendetta yeah i think
it's a targeted attack
what if it's like a rival because you
know it's like a bicycler who's just
like man you're stealing my thunder
right now or the tricycle maybe it's a
competing street performer because you
have to yeah they only reserve certain
amount of slots or it's a sick unicycle
or et1 or something or it was a
type r or there was like silver paint on
the [ __ ] uh on the door handle
because the guy that punched through it
is the [ __ ]
silver guy
he even pushed it like yeah
it's a street performer
he's getting away
damn
you're getting tips this is the rose
gold one oh yeah you just don't know
which one which one it is this guy's
just way too [ __ ] popular and they're
getting jealous he is popular yeah
they're like if they take away his
[ __ ] unicorn yeah that's his [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's if he doesn't have that
that's like a samurai without a sword
what is he gonna do now street show
people really do beef it because there's
a limited amount of space you can't just
like go there and perform you gotta buy
a permit and then if someone already has
that spot you can't get it it's not
enough street out there no they really
do beef that [ __ ] dude they do they take
it real serious i uh so i did a video a
couple years ago and it was like because
i remember seeing all these street
carnies you know
and uh and there was always like this
spider-man beef where like there's like
a guy out there as spider-man and then
he's pissed that there's another guy out
there spider-man so i hired a [ __ ] ton
of guys on actors access and i bought a
[ __ ] ton of spider-man costumes and i
flooded the entire street like all
hollywood island with just spider-man it
was just all spider-man everywhere
and then all the street cars were
getting so [ __ ] pissed and all the
spider-man guys were like we're [ __ ]
for the whole day it's over it's [ __ ]
over and i was like we're free we're a
hundred percent free you can take
pictures with us no big deal
i [ __ ] all those guys up and then the
guy who's the guy who's in the bumblebee
costume he takes his job real [ __ ]
seriously he was extra pissed because
he's like you guys are [ __ ] our whole
thing up and i'm like hey dude i'm like
you want to work on this street it all
goes through me
you're the street performer mafia that's
exactly who was stealing the [ __ ]
unicycle it was like fat tony
what the the juggler
you think you could [ __ ] joke on my
blog
dude the street carnies are [ __ ]
interesting i mean you guys remember in
venice beach that one cat who had um
rollerblades on and he would always take
had the guitar out yeah is he the buff
guy with the purple spell he's like this
bearded guy he like always looks like
very sun bleached and like
yeah he's like i had like a rastafarian
vibe to him but yeah he's he sounds like
everybody out there
yes yeah grand piano guy
he's like a homeless with a grand piano
he rolls it's like covered in bird [ __ ]
and graffiti and [ __ ] and he always
pushes that holy [ __ ] and i'm like how
does a homeless man have a full-on grand
piano that he can roll all the way out
to ben's venice beach how does he even
store it have you guys seen this people
want to see steve just hire a bunch of
people with grand pianos
i run this whole [ __ ] blog
have you guys seen the street performers
in waikiki
yeah there's a couple there's one old
guy
he's like it's a older white dude and he
has he has a little keyboard and he
makes music but it's very like odd
like electronic music but he makes
noises with his voice and he goes uh
see this is like mongolian throat
singing yeah but it's like in really
weird pitches
yeah and he dude he's killing it there's
all these people that circle around and
he's right by the [ __ ] rip curl store
and the whole time he's just making
these weird robotic i don't i don't
understand the appeal to it but he
attracts the crowd and he's there every
[ __ ] night i do i do love seeing
those people that have like 16
instruments including the mouth
harmonica and stuff and they're just
like playing everything at the same time
i think that's sick as [ __ ] whereas like
bucket drummers that could be very
obnoxious sometimes no i always go to
the bucket drivers i'm like you got a cd
because i want to hear this all the
[ __ ] time 24 1765
i'm going out playing suit i need
something to listen to for four and a
half hours
and what do they say
they're like no no yeah the dogs were
asking them
i bet you that inspired them to actually
make an album now
because of you oh my god oh my god cause
all the buckets mostly sound the same
that's the best if you're if you're if
you're a big fan they might have second
thoughts
they just need to have more than one
bucket and if so when there's a
secondary sound there's so much more
dynamic to the offering yeah some of
those guys bring pots and pans and [ __ ]
now which is which is better but if it's
just one bucket though it's kind of the
same tone just really fast home depot
buckets like yeah it's so lazy but but
if it's a bucket and a cowbell suddenly
i'm like okay i could be entertained
like twice as long now a didgeridoo
a didgeridoo a big pipe thing yeah dude
yeah
yeah i saw some
i was in the middle of maui in this town
called paella um
used to be an old plantation town that's
now just like full of hippies and like
trust fund kids that are trying to find
themselves and i was walking around
and i turn around and i hear that noise
wow and i'm like what the [ __ ]
it's some
it's some like hippie dreadlocked white
dude with no shirt tattered ass pants
and it's just going wang
and i was like what how did you even get
here dude
it was the oddest [ __ ] thing seeing
those hippy white uh dudes that are like
dreaded that are like buddhists and
stuff like that
just roaming everywhere they're like
everyone with like hair and pants
parachute pants and stuff rastafarian
like he's doing this all the time
this is when i was like i have a
vendetta against white people with
dreadlocks i don't i don't i don't know
what it is i have a vendetta what about
asian guys or dreadlocks yeah if you're
my friend's little brother's like that
yes yes the answer is yes
because there was this kid in our school
and he sat near us in high school and he
would spit in his hand
why
i was like is that how dreadlocks are
made you gotta spit on it i don't know i
don't think that so that means their
hair is full of spit oh i have no idea
but he had dreadlocks he had like white
dread like white-haired he would just do
this and then put it through his hair no
he would he it was him rolling his
dreadlocks up oh his hair's in his hands
in class and i would just be like am i
the only one that feels some type of way
about it and i think i was i was did it
smell
i never got yeah he he smelled he
definitely smelled his whole self
smelled he just smelled it yeah
he was a nice guy but i was like hey man
just just get a regular haircut
just get a regular haircut i'm going to
try getting the red locks now i want to
try and get it bro you can still rep
what you're going to wrap with regular
hair it's a whole thing right have you
had dreadlocks no but i um
three guys on my crew have and it's hard
yeah so like it's a it's a process
because like even like that the way you
quote unquote wash your hair is like
different because they don't really wash
it right really wash them yeah they use
like some different like products and
stuff sometimes like rarely to go
through it yeah or like just the way
that you have to uh
[ __ ] like if you get it dirty you
know if there's sand and you go to the
beach and they're like standing and
stuff like that it's like usually it's a
pain in the ass deal with it whereas for
me if i don't wash my hair for like
three days i'm getting all itchy and
[ __ ] like that and i'm like so the idea
of it is cool but i i don't know how
they do it
um i'd have to ask seems like a lot of
maintenance but also like you know
research might work for somebody like
you i'm pretty greasy bro i get an itchy
head oh [ __ ] this story is actually in
pakistan my bad
[Music]
[Music]